Let's take a closer look at that
some of strings function definition.
Function definitions
take the general form.
We start with the func
[MUSIC]
Oops not that funk.
So func followed by the function
name then a pair of parenthesis,
inside the parentheses,
you'll find the parameters.
Taking the form, parameter name,
colon, parameter type.
Then an arrow pointing
to the return type.
Followed by the executable
statements between curly braces.
So if we look at our
sum of strings method,
we see that it takes in a parameter
called a bunch of strings.
That parameter's of type array,
holding items of type string,
and this function returns
an object of type int.
Let's look at another example.
You've also seen this code before.
The name of this function
is reversedString.
It takes in the string as a parameter,
a parameter named a stringToReverse and
it returns an object of type string.
Keep in mind that not every
function returns an object.
For example, if reversedString printed
out its result instead of returning it,
the function signature would look
like this no return type, and
since there's no return type,
no arrow either.